hello everybody and welcome to minecraft
together with coaster BOTS over here
have a good see it yes it's great to see
you as well especially in this this
grave yes yeah why are we playing
Minecraft it's it's a bit of a long
story but I'm gonna try to explain this
in a sort of short way so we met up in
wallaby Holland this summer and I
honestly don't even know the exact
context anymore but at some point a
conversation drifted to the topic of
Minecraft and we pinky promised to make
a Minecraft video together Perry you're
absolutely the worst what's the next
video minecraft survival games
420 yes yes we'll have a clap yes
pinkie promise you now we're gonna have
to do a Minecraft yeah so this is this
is a very very ambitious crossover you
could say and it just so happens to be
that I am a moderator I don't know if
you know this story actually but I'm a
moderator on a Facebook meme server well
it's not really a server it's a group
but at some point somebody in the group
decided let's make a minecraft server
somebody threw some money at it and now
we had a minecraft server and me being a
moderator I felt very yeah I don't know
I felt like I had a sense of
responsibility for this place you know
mm-hmm it fits into the whole plan of
recording a micros video together it
does so yeah that's that's where we're
at we're at the server of what in Dutch
is called mythical memes for the easy
man if I okay
it's a beautiful Dutch Facebook server
and what's interesting to notes about
this that this is Dutch language focused
so there's also a lot of Belgian
influences mm-hmm and there's not really
any rules except for you know no
griefing or anything so there are some
really weird stuff like the big tall
lanky wooden tower over there beautiful
creation but I yeah it's uh it's
honestly it's been an eyesore and I've
always been wanting to put some flint
and steel on to the bottom of it it's
just a burn down all the way still now
well that's somebody's creation
well let's do it okay that's too quick
have you ever got Flint steel oh I've
gotta have anything
is there a furnace I can make one
honestly maybe we could look inside here
so this is basically everybody just sort
of settled throughout the the server and
it's a group of islands so it's pretty
cool everybody has their own sort of
Island and the Belgian people settled on
this spawns Island over here and they
probably hopefully found on his planes
I've already got some Flint oh that's
one I'm okay so if you're watching this
Rick I'm sorry about burning your wooden
tower down break it just had to be done
mate honestly next time build a better
tower and come can you climb up to the
top should we burn it from the top yeah
you can yeah perfect what's on the
redstone about it's our blood I remember
at some point he used to have a lot of
chickens in here like every floor is
just full of chickens I don't know where
all those things went hmm but um but for
you also put doors on every single floor
right so there's a front door on every
single floor for some reason its fire
spread actually on it should be it is on
okay cool
we're going up there oh sure you might
want to get going yeah yeah good oh oh
that's beautiful look at that all that
it's pretty nice actually
hopefully it you know it burns mostly to
the ground yeah it might actually just
leave a few yeah we can go to a land
called Sylvania which is my own place so
over there yeah that's like the the
modern building so I could see the
buildings we need a boat yeah no we are
so there's actually some pretty
elaborate transport systems training and
yeah there's a train station right here
where do you get the minecarts from oh
you can get one from me here thank you
we should go so put it on this one um no
no not that one why not not that one not
that there's two reels and one of them
goes to Sylvania the other one doesn't
right should be signpost it's not
signpost yes it is but it's in Dutch on
the right it's a minion yeah okay
cousin you go first and I'll follow okay
so sit here I know how to do this oh
[ __ ] wait what the [ __ ] how I'll go
again oh no this is fat I didn't realize
it that gave you so much boost yeah it's
pretty insane honestly oh you came back
uh no that might just be like okay it's
that well I just well I just want to put
out there that we spent 45 minutes
trying to get this game and our audio to
work we did so hopefully this is good I
mean this is probably gonna be some long
gas episode because I'm not good yeah
for sure
I've got better things to do then edit
this together so same here if you ever
seen one of these so this is like a new
feature right it's a water elevator it
shoots you up crazy fast whoa how does I
used to make them but not not like this
how does that work so all you do now is
you put source end underneath water
blocks
oh it just creates these bubbles and you
go up we used to have water elevators
that were on a sign water sign water and
then you just hold space and you go oh
yeah those things yeah back in the day
so welcome on sylvania yep
thank you it's all done quite legit yeah
that's all legit I put way too much
effort into this I didn't see that I
could see so if we go in here this is
like the the main sort of part awesome
in this polar bear that's a new thing
don't hit him don't hit him whatever you
do what about the throne again no oh
he's also called goodwill ders which is
a Dutch politician so this is this is my
base mm-hmm it's pretty nice and cozy I
suppose yep is this station well here's
a bit of a tower with like storage and
vertical farming stuff here's my own
house where I have my bed and my jukebox
and we could play some music guys
yeah I can't hear it but hopefully the
views came out again so this is yes for
18 caps beautiful I remember the old
minecraft music jeez it's actually super
nostalgic yeah it really is right music
in general as well yeah it is
okay so here we've the farms and stuff
I mean what's there to explain I know
yeah so that's all quite nice here's the
the nether portal and actually that's
that's pretty much the entire island
it's quite small hmm wow you got some
sort of monorail system in the nether as
well oh you're yeah you're in the nether
yeah yeah yeah we do what is it go
Maurice it goes to most of the places
because you know truffula oh yes
eight times quicker hey yeah so you can
go to most of the parts of the map here
we also have a thing going to the end
which is very interesting but I think I
have something which will interest you
yeah very particular item I should say
right there's a beautiful thing in that
chest right why don't you go ahead and
check that out nice nice yep that's the
bench Annoying Orange we're on a meme
server I guess so you get these things
yeah from time to time why they're all
chickens in all the boats that I've seen
so far
wait what the holiday Oh what's this oh
those are fish what I don't know why
they're jumping out of the ah this fish
in the game like actually a cool fish
like actual fish you can see it why did
that take so long to do well these are
all animated as well holy moly it's a
whole new game they have this new thing
called the conduits and it's a really
hard item to get like it's super
expensive but I place one underneath my
island and it means that you can now
swim indefinitely you're like your
breath
that's cool this is very cool
swimming man that's like wow you want to
have a boat maybe we could explore the
seas yeah yeah man I like are the items
float up to the top
yeah that's pretty nice as much better
than it used to be I think I'm just
gonna have to kick out some chickens
here
why does a boat sink everything else
floats how does have work who decided I
know the boat item will sink that
doesn't make sense if a boat you know
ends up catching water it sinks I'm
sorry about squeaky super squeaky this
is the island of two Belgian dudes this
is this is also the guys who built the
Belgian flags everywhere I'm like their
territory the big sign says it's this
Dutch language mean that's the thing in
the group it just says epic you you
could probably recognize that it says
epic greetings I mean it's I can't even
explain it underneath it's a meme but
it's a meme it's a name yeah that's what
my sons are like that yeah exactly so if
we go further a little bit it's just one
thing I want to really quickly show and
then we'll go into another direction
like how you can drift the boats so
here's the big mountain with XD on it
doubled anyone added an extra D I don't
know why mm-hmm yeah this is this is
what we're all about to miss over I
thought I was gonna you know turn the
whole sea into land as Dutch people do
know better the hell out of it and
create yeah and but I I stopped with
just a little bit of landed turned
boring really quickly I can imagine and
then over there there's a castle she's
quite nice I think also built by some
Belgian dude you if you go here right
there's another big sign that says Ben
Sharpie Oh annoying orange Oh beautiful
so that was built by me actually I was
really bored so that's what you decide
to do yeah yeah exactly
that's always building over there on the
left yeah it's uh that's a friend of
mine built that put way too much time
into it blind ship yeah so that's
something from the end as well where he
went to the end and just gathered all of
this interesting purple stone and built
a ship out of it there's also the weird
purple flowers over there oh yeah oh wow
and as well what the hell's happening to
me I just got poisoned happenings oh I
think I know what that might be it might
be uh actually I don't know it's a fish
well yeah there's a puffer fish over
here and it seen any more is it was down
here in any case it was a puffer fish
and those things are like toxic when you
come too close okay
retro knee but yeah this is this is
basically his enormous house I don't
know if I can show you anything there
well he he has this really cool thing
where he built this this underwater
village I think he calls it Atlantis
very original
yes I'm saying just trying to use the
power of the conduits to see and breathe
underwater so it was like a bunch of
buildings down here and stuff oh and
this is the conduits yeah this is what
you get like a breathing power from
what's the range on this thing that's
really like a hundred blocks or
something it's pretty good quite long
and all right so it just literally built
a house of it yeah and over here just
like the the rainbow sheep I don't know
how he does it he literally just
constantly change color Oh what yeah
what that is an Oracle chip maybe that's
why they change color because real cool
yep oh yeah no that's it I think that's
an easter egg good point because he's
one of the developers yep all right what
color to get a view Shira I think just
the original color that they had which
is probably like a red or blue light or
something I actually had some really
cool stuff right because he's he's done
all this this crazy things that I didn't
have the time for and one of them is I
think he has an aquarium somewhere
oh it's downstairs oh yes two actually
how far down are we talking not here
yeah over here so basically you catch
all these fish and you just put them in
here all the different fish yeah Wow
and the next update I think is also
gonna have a different glass texture so
you don't get these weird annoy yeah
excells anymore
because I'll be much better yeah and
he's like insane oh yeah and he also has
coral in this one
oh look at those fish jeez yeah pretty
cool isn't it
yeah are you thinking about going back
to my crush no I do not have the time to
spend with playing this game and I don't
have a motivation to fight the game
either that makes sense
I don't like playing minecraft by myself
or like grinding or so flat not yeah
exactly I just kind of had the motive to
do it
mmm because of this server you know what
though I think we can go to the end I
think it would be interesting to see
have you ever been to the end yeah ever
be to the end what questions that no
minecraft like eight years have I never
been to the end well maybe you're not
very good at the game I really can't
make assumptions i D well the con you
have I don't have it I'm I'm afraid I
don't have a card for you so I want to
go you go see you later in the back wait
is it possible to know you can't have
two people on a single card right sure
on it anyway
in that case I'm gonna it's not even
that much fun slow is that all but if we
go to the end it's really far away we
only have a coins for that so not
hopefully there's one in here like
there's one in here
I got it already nice so lead the way
well yeah I'll put my cart in here then
you're gonna kind of push yourself and
jump in you could push yourself with the
arrow keys yeah I know
shut up see you know even a true gamer
like me and what a time to be alive yeah
this is a what what kind of timeline are
we even living in by the timeline we're
like two rollercoaster youtubers are
making a Minecraft video it's crazy in
it matter
oh [ __ ] there's a guest over there hey
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] where we go we need to go
into the portal all right ComNet awake
before he destroys the portal [ __ ]
okay then yeah yeah okay okay nice nice
alright so jump in yes the end over here
yeah that I know and watch out watch out
don't don't kill yourself because this
is all you know the void and we gotta go
down here the water or just take the
ladder that's pretty safe option whoo
true gamer yeah I can see that I see you
ever risen up
I never roast out mate what what what is
she going on here
it's an Enderman farm ah so if we go
here oh yeah there's a ton of annemun
over there how did they die oh
suffocation oh they shouldn't die of
suffocation I guess there's just so many
then they're all dying of suffocation
the [ __ ] was that explosion Yoshi
ow I'm getting a towel oh sorry that's
unless you're him to me yeah yeah they
actually dying with suffocate
no they shouldn't I think it's just so
many that they're dying how do you is
that explosion how do you father like
this so you need yeah you just do that
basically but the best thing is I have
like needed a sweep attack right with
the sword yeah that's why you use it all
at the same time and then you just Lu
just a whole bunch of them if you get
too close you just AoE the person oh
right I'm sorry
you can have fun with this but I think
it's the best XP forum so much
expectation ish it's actually insane
saying on the amount of XP you get I
might even picking up XP anymore for
some reason even though she was swimming
around you there you got it
what level are you know 27 no I just got
loads of these big boys here's the thing
to built this farm we turned off like
that you lose your inventory when you're
dying so we could pretty much just jump
into the void and end up somewhere I
think
yay so yeah that's uh that's most of the
server and I think actually how'd you
like it yeah I mean you you've done some
impressive things a lot more than I've
ever done I mean all I ever do playing
minecraft was usually like tactical
stuff like my friend is or self smelting
furnaces that kind of thing auto phone
right I never really found it
interesting through architecture more
kind of technical stuff that just saves
time like efficient stuff at the same
time I never really played Minecraft
when I was this old you know I haven't
played my clothes it's right into
another
I haven't played Minecraft properly when
I haven't been like 14
so mmm I think now I'd be able to do a
bit more things you know yeah probably I
only play PvP now the only the old style
looks but the new style is hard honestly
I just build stuff yeah it's all I like
to do and for some reason I like to do
in survival you know gather the
materials and that sort of that sort of
stuff but I still
suck at PvP oh I have a cool weapon
actually it's called a trident it's this
new weapon that they add it into the
game and it's like oh oh yeah I say I
was trying to get up there that's
impossible that's not my dream I'm up
where are you at the top vogue wait you
can you can throw that hi-yah
I didn't even know that Wow hold on
mister [ __ ] just hit you practically
gonna have an art not going let me to
stand back a little bit so you can get
any like they get right here right yeah
oh yeah you've hit the Bob no oh [ __ ]
you stuck it nice oh no you okay what
you need to end up ah yeah yeah nice
beautiful I'm really glad that we're
recording this video because we only
paid for the server for three months
also
so those three months I think are over
in a few days I really his whole world
is gonna be lost forever what no one
saved it surely someone will save it god
someone has the world file but nobody
cares yeah okay that's that's when a
minecraft project really dies mmm it's
true but what's really interesting is
this thing called a trident mm-hmm
that's yeah yeah right it's it's the
sort of spear thing you can throw to
kill mobs now Wow high school if you get
this one enchantment it automatically
flies back to you wherever you throw it
so it's like a pretty overpowered weapon
wait if you got that yeah yeah so if I
throw it you get like this I already
cracked little rope that gives it back
to you I just threw out
kenapa oh yeah you could try it tried it
Cisco Oh see it's awesome right is okay
yourself it just automatically comes
back it don't have to do anything
yeah excuse him what a throwaway joke
kill the chicken I think that's the
achievement for using the Trident this
is she only as hell yeah no I just
brought the boat Jesus I like this this
is good umm I guess that's it then yeah
that's just about it
that's uh it's been fun having you in
this server yeah no thanks for showing
me around yeah thanks for letting me
film the the pinky-promise
finally recorded my cross video yes it's
been a long time waiting and a house has
always been a dream for me to record a
Minecraft video together so high yeah
it's been country you know problem and
for all of the viewers out there if
you're an english-speaking viewer I'm
sorry but if you're a Dutch speaking
viewer check out the Facebook page
nevermind check out the Facebook page
meet Lisa memes for the mock ligaments
because it's a great Facebook page
lots of memes lots of fun not a micro
server anymore in a few days but so you
can check it out if you're into meme
culture and for everybody else thank you
for watching and we'll see you all
thanks I will see you next time in
Minecraft
see somewhere else no April Fool's 2019
alright Oh we'll call it a day holy [ __ ]
let's just hope every 45 minutes
oh no [ __ ]